two million followers is quite an
enormous responsibility it's technology
like anything else that mankind creates
is a tool and that tool can be used for
good or for evil like a lightsaber and
the technology is supposed to bring
people together streamline things and
make life easier and in a lot of ways it
does that however technology can also
disconnect you from other people and
break down the the social network the
real social network of family and
friends and interpersonal communication
and isolate people make them feel alone
make them feel small so it's a tool that
needs to be used correctly trying to
think of an analogy and I can't think of
one but I'll just say that you know I
use two million Twitter followers as it
as a tool I the reason I have twitter is
so people can get to know me as a
different person other than Dwight I
just realized all of a sudden like Oh
everyone thinks I'm Dwight they think
that I'm Dwight from the office and that
I'm this kind of annoying a difficult
nerdy creepy guy and oh they don't know
Rainn Wilson although I'm a little bit
nerdy annoying and creepy I'm not as
much as Dwight Schrute and it's a way
for them to get to know my sense of
humor and my passion projects like
SoulPancake and so that's the purpose
that it serves but I don't want Twitter
to be a time suck I don't want it to
take me away from my family and from
what's important it's just a tool that I
use